highly active antiretroviral therapy or
heart is widely used to treat HIV AIDS
heart prevents HIV from replicating
itself by inhibiting the ccr5 receptor
HIV reverse transcriptase HIV integrase
or HIV protease let's start with ccr5
the viral glycoprotein 120 on the
surface of HIV binds to the host cell
cd4 receptor and the ccr5 receptor once
HIV successfully binds to the receptors
the cell merges with the virus and the
viral RNA and proteins are injected into
the cell Mara Barak is a specific ccr5
receptor antagonist that prevents HIV
from entering host cells by attaching to
the ccr5 receptor second HIV reverse
transcriptase is an enzyme utilized by
HIV that uses host cells nucleotides
transcribed the viral RNA into DNA the
viral RNA is transcribed into an RNA DNA
helix then RNA is cleaved from the DNA
strand and a DNA helix is formed a drug
nevirapine binds to the HIV reverse
transcriptase and inhibits the enzyme by
altering the active site third integrase
is an enzyme that integrates HIV s DNA
into the host genome HIV integrase
begins by grabbing two ends of the HIV
DNA created by reverse transcriptase and
slicing it into the hosts chromosomes
raw egg Revere is an integration hitter
drug that has two metal binding groups
it competes with DNA to bind with
integrase and it's reception inhibits
the enzyme the last enzyme that will be
addressed as HIV one protease let's
start with some background information
translation occurs when HIV mRNA in host
cells tRNA interact to produce a long
polypeptide chain the long polypeptide
chain is non-functional requires aid of
a protease protease cuts the long
polypeptide into short functional HIV
units sak whenever is a protease
inhibitor drug that binds to the active
site of protease and thus halts the
cleavage of polypeptides more than 1.2
million people in the United States are
living with an HIV infection and almost
1 in 7 are unaware of their infection
stop the spread of HIV and get tested
today